followed by a review of what i covered
this month in physics and then we're
going to open up first the questions uh
the the floral for questions that people
have made since last time and then real
time okay that will work in that
direction okay let's go with the first
one uh i got a lot of uh
static for
giving getting my shot
okay
and um so people don't a lot of people
didn't like that and these are some of
the kind i couldn't put all the comments
that they put but here here's some of
the comments that came up there and
first it says all you had to do was wait
a year and you could travel
and another if else sounds like you're
dying to go on holiday and that's how
the the questions came or the comments
came out
uh
well what can i say um
in my case you know everybody's got a
different situation
my case uh the united states government
has prevented uh
my wife and i from
from living together for over 20 years
now
so everybody's got a different situation
then you still have to look at this
whole thing in a different light and
again within the
extinction theory okay keep this in mind
and it goes something like this let's
say uh they give you a sentence
a death sentence
you're going to the electric chair in
one month
here comes the doctor to your cell and
says
we want to give you a shot
in in the arm
of the gun right
yeah i'll give you a shot in your arm
i mean you're going to die in one month
do you think you're you're going to care
they give you a shot yeah go ahead just
i mean
it's more or less like that and you got
something you want to tell me about you
yeah
i mean how do you get the shop for uh
what is it a year and a half uh i get it
now because i had to travel or i'm going
to travel and i don't want the hassle
and so they said something along those
lines says
uh someone said it's not a vaccine
it's a genetic
serum okay
now the foul says you didn't take a fax
as it is not one you took a gene therapy
drug and that is official
so uh some people say that i'm not i'm
destroying my genes or changing my genes
i guess by getting my shot right you
you're mutating now yeah something like
that someone says look at brandy wagon
and
this lady died
she was in her 40s she died quite early
died of unrelated causes to the
vaccine but she worked for a
company a company a pharmaceutical
company and became an atheist in
in pharmaceuticals and drugs and in
that whole business of uh medicine and a
lot of people are just like her so they
look up to people like her who go out
there and
talk against doctors and hospitals and
the whole business of medicine right
and yeah i mean everybody reaches his
own conclusion there there is a lot of
commerce out there and so i don't blame
people who question
all of what's going on out there you
know but
again everybody's got to reach his own
conclusion the the issue the way i look
at it you don't want to take
uh
an extremist view and become a flat
earther
in the medicine world you know
uh you can go with conspiracies as
only so far and after that it gets
ridiculous sometimes so
just keep that in mind that's the
context okay and final favorite said uh
you've been exposed as a fool i will no
longer watch this youtube channel
exposed it makes it sound like it's a
it's a secret
no
the the issue here is is
it's that
there's a lot of militancy and a lot of
debate going on for this issue for me
it's a non-issue i have a friend who who
if if his friend if his job made him
vast to keep working he'd quit
yeah yeah a lot of people are are very
strong in their beliefs for and against
this by the way okay before and against
uh there's a big debate out there lots
of articles lots of people talking about
this for me it's a non-issue altogether
okay totally unrelated to anything that
i do or even think about i'm not even
concerned about it the only reason i got
the vaccine is i don't want to fight
city hall okay if you want to go fight
city hall
hey my guess
knock yourself out i mean
yeah i mean i don't want to go through
the house and let me show you some
examples here um
here you have chicago tribune uh now ask
unvaccinated travelers to quarantine
okay
uh washington examiner biden
administration tells unvaccinated people
don't travel over label day weekend
they're gonna put all kinds of uh stuff
in front of you right barons uh europe
wants un vaccinated americans to stay
home okay so uh and it's bad news for
airline stocks you better believe it uh
you know i wouldn't buy be buying
airline stocks just now maybe later on
but not now unvaccinated people are
becoming second classes yeah and look
here here you get an uh an even worse
case
you talk about the government
interfering in your life well here how
about this one okay here's this lady and
the judge asked a mother if she got the
coronavirus vaccine she said no and he
revoked custody of her son
[Laughter]
so uh i don't know if you want to i mean
if you want to fight city hall go ahead
you know i've got better things to do
especially you know i'm i don't think i
have that many years left in me so i'm
not going to fight this thing it doesn't
matter to me okay you maybe you might
think differently i don't know
i'm not vaccinated yeah but i mean if uh
if uh again if
you're on death row
and you got i don't know a month to live
or two months to live do you think i
don't i don't think you would care i
don't think you would say oh no it's so
against my maybe out of like principles
just a piss yeah that's that's the only
reason but but i mean yeah
the conspiracy theory around vaccines
that makes uh that makes sense logically
a person in his 50s 60s or 70s probably
won't uh get harmed by it then again a
senior citizen in 80s or 90s might be
too fragile to receive it the vaccine is
never personalized enough to the
receiver's uh immune system
and uh yeah keep in mind here's uh
here's something that came out on the
news and gives you an idea where this
stands okay
uh you have who you know the world
health organization monitoring uh new
coronavirus variant named moo
so we have the moo coming on
and
you know they're they've got all these
variants are they real are they not real
and
you know they vaccinate you against one
does that protect you against the other
you know say we got all these issues out
there and again that's why i don't care
about the uh the vaccine itself it it
doesn't it doesn't do anything for me
yeah yeah we got more corona virus
because like as far as
like changing our lives it hasn't really
changed much but for me i haven't
changed literally anything except
no you have to you have to wear a mask
yeah other than that
it's no biggie uh and again some people
say well if you catch it then you're
gonna be sorry and uh you you'll read
tons of cases out there you'll read tons
of cases of people who got the vaccine
and died anyways you get all kinds of
cases you don't even know what to
believe anymore you know so this is
going to be one of those 20 20 hindsight
things yeah in hindsight i was gonna be
like oh you should have got the vaccine
or oh you shouldn't yeah uh personally
uh i don't care about it if i get the
bug assuming there is a bug for those of
you who don't believe that there's a bug
i die that's it but we're done i mean i
don't care either way and
again the only reason i got the vaccine
is to travel
so they don't you know hassle me
okay another fellow brings up the issue
uh that says previous to the viral scam
the medical industry was the third
leading cause of death
by admitted reported medical errors
bill's mother probably lived longer by
not going to this incompetent cluster
and i talked about the fact that my
mother died of cancer to the uterus and
died at the age of 62. had she had an
operation she probably would have lived
longer this fall thinks otherwise but
the issue there is that everybody's
becoming you know an expert
in health everybody's a shaman now you
know
everybody goes to google whenever they
have a problem they say oh why does uh
my eye hurt oh it must be this and and
so they try to cure themselves
one question there is when the end of
the world comes around you're the last
human on earth or one of the last few
right
uh
do you have a doctor available
to you i mean you have all these
preppers and uh survivalists survivalist
hunter who goes out there and thinks
he's gonna be hunt living off the uh
deer that he hunts and a
prepper is a guy who is a gardener
he's gonna be do gardening and doing
gardening and so the question is do you
have a doctor
do you have a dentist i mean here you
stop having a pain in your tooth real
bad pain and there's no one around to
cure you are you going to do what the
guy in the uh
i hope you're brave enough okay
to do it to yourself because there's
gonna be no one around you know to uh to
treat you
okay um
had a couple of religious folk come
around says evolution bs and another
fellow also says bill takes evolution
for fact then describes species
degeneration
okay um yeah but see these people
believe uh in the bible and they believe
that uh god turned silicon into carbon
you know he took a little bit of clay
okay
and made a man out of it
[Laughter]
uh we do that typically in these
accelerators they are able to do
transmutations you know a little bit
uh god did it without all that machinery
he just took his hands and
blew life into some clay and turned it
into carbon dude's got a point though oh
you don't okay what's the point okay
that's obvious okay i thought evolution
uh
is about getting stronger and growing
and and species degeneration and
gene washing out over time
uh is an argument for the opposite yeah
yeah in that sense uh yeah but see this
is the the problem there that i see is
that people use the wrong words uh what
you'll find out there is that uh
so-called scientists biologists whatever
they're called
uh they go out there and they say um
uh you know that he had the right tools
to survive uh
or they talk about better and worse it's
got nothing to do with better and worse
or with being successful these are the
words they use those are all you know
qualifiers that don't belong in the
discussion
yeah because
what the success will mean we're all
gonna die all species are gonna die
eventually so what do you mean six stuff
just means you had a kid before you died
yeah and that kid lived long enough to
advocate
the language is wrong well we shouldn't
talk about success and uh survival of
the fittest it's not the fittest it's
the guy who survived
though success is nice as binaries if
did you live long enough to have a kid
or not oh is that what it is is that
what success is about that's how you
define it and evolutionarily
maybe because i would say that success
is the guy who doesn't have kids
or that yeah
the guy just enjoys his life and dies
right maybe that's guys success i'm
saying like evolutionarily speaking
usually they that's how they qualify i
know but this what i'm saying that's the
wrong language they should not use that
kind of language at least in science i
mean you want to talk about
this kind of stuff at the water cooler
fine but
in science you should not talk about
success and survival of the fittest and
all this kind of this is also
opinionated yeah it's just expensive has
that opinion weight to it like well if
you call it success yeah
so so this is the issue i mean you know
wrong wording
uh okay um another issue here
um
paul says to support bill's extinction
theory the un's high ambition
coalition
uh wrote a document in 2020 that said a
mass extinction event is well underway
the un also comes out
uh
a gar report every two years which
discusses global collapse with scenarios
but do those scenarios always involve uh
pandemics well uh that's that's the next
point and the next point is you know
what are those
um
mechanisms scenarios okay and here you
have this is from the wikipedia okay and
so you've got first the uh ecological
the this is the ecological group what do
they put climate change pandemic so we
do have pandemic in there already
halfway there uh human activity they say
we're in the sixth mass extinction okay
by human activity they mean like we're
displacing animals and plants but not
just that it's also we're destroying our
own environment for ourselves yeah
essentially that's what they're saying
that but partly because we're destroying
it and partly because we're using we're
clearing the land the forest jungles so
that we can plant stuff that's good for
us you know so it's all a mixture of all
that and by doing that we're displacing
all the animals we're crowding them out
nitrogen fixation they talk about the
nitrogen cycle you know like if that's
got something to do with anything uh
freshwater depletion uh overpopulation
okay they say that we
we are
um using up resources faster than uh can
be naturally replaced or replenished
um
birth dates rising in the 21st century
in the developed world that might happen
they say okay
uh and science you know the magazine uh
certain human population will grow to 11
billion by 2100 and that growth will
continue into the next century
uh-huh so these are these are what these
people have in the backs of their minds
so what i can say to that is these
people have no clue whatsoever what
they're talking about okay because uh
population is declining it's declining
irreversible population growth is
difficult but uh yeah population growth
is declining
it's declining irreversibly and that
means we're going to reach zpg at some
point quite soon i believe it
reversively is
irreversible no yes
yeah yeah
and i'm saying that irreversibly because
because
uh our population pyramid has overturned
when it does for any species it can
never be turned back again and what i
mean is you know when a species is old
not when it's young it's just had a uh
what is it a uh bottleneck you know of
some kind okay anyways population
decline through a preference for fewer
children okay
in developing world demographics are
soon to be developed world demographics
some projections suggest an extinction
before the year 3000 and his fellow
leslie mathematician he says well that
might even happen in the year twenty
four hundred well how about if they uh
consider that might happen in six years
or so uh could that happen
and some levels suggest the demographic
transition may reverse itself due to
evolutionary biology absolutely not
never will happen okay and then of
course you have the super volcanic
eruption you have to put that one in
then you finish it with a bang yeah
because uh that's how the permian
animals supposedly died there was a
volcanic activity because that's the pet
peeve of uh the people who work in pert
in the permian extinction it is badass
yeah yeah it's great but you can't
explain selectivity with that song you
can
a coincidence
the rocks hit the right hand yeah
and then uh that that was the ecological
now they have another set and that's
first the technological one is the
nuclear and biological well i'm sorry
it's ties to terrorists
the aliens are coming
then they have mitigate disease
outbreaks so we have again uh diseases
in there okay creators of super
intelligent entity we're gonna create
these super intelligence you know these
robots terminator you're actually
talking about terminating yeah you're
gonna kill us we're gonna make ai the
smarter than us and that finds us
obviously eating kills right something
like that they've actually been watching
too much matrix yeah that's that's what
it is a lot of too much information and
even then the matrix doesn't kill us it
just makes us well better that's in the
movie
on reality
uncontrolled nano technology a creation
of a micro black hole i mean these
people really right you never know when
you make a black hole oh yeah sometimes
they go into the bathroom and make
something and then you have the again
genetic engineering creates a new
species so we become
something different than we are today
there's no humans or trans humans so
that would be uh is that like uh
is that would that be like an extinction
that they suspect the neanderthals died
of the fact that
the neanderthals didn't die out they
just turned into us so in that sense we
would die out because because we turned
into the next thing yeah yeah but it
gets worse because in the case of trans
humans uh you don't need your body
anymore it's just the intelligence
floating on oh yeah
that is the matrix right there okay
extra terrestrial especially nasa
sponsored okay geological or
cosmological disaster extraterrestrial
event like asteroids etc supernova gamma
ray that kind of thing sun's stellar
evolution might happen in a billion
years heat death of the universe now
we're talking about billions of years
and then we can be invaded by
militarily superior extraterrestrials
and of course if they invade us they
absolutely must be militarily and
otherwise superior to us
is there any mention
of food collapse due to the fact that
our economy collapses okay now now
you're pulling straws come on now you're
fully strong so
why isn't that theory in the in the
wikipedia okay why do we have all these
idiotic theories yeah it's not even on
there that's kind of weird that food
shortage isn't even yeah it's not even
considered anything it's like nobody
even ponders the fact
you go to the super american foods there
what do you mean bill what are you
talking about it's not even like
considered like written down but this is
unlikely it's not even like that it's
just like it's not even
pondered
not even discussed
nobody even considers an economic
collapse and so
the question is all these u n guys you
know all they talk about is the same
nonsense that the paleontologists the
mathematicians all these people feed
them uh post-humanists and futurologists
they all talk about the same thing but
just all this nonsense that you i just
read you know no one talks about
economic collapse and so the question
you should ask yourself because you know
very few people visit this site is
you're one of the few at least that's
exposed to the theory whether you
believe it or not but the question
you're exposed to the rest of the world
does he is completely blindsided to it
especially those people who run the
world they're blindsided to it that's
true okay yeah even preppers are
blindsided because they have they have
like uh they have like a close version
close they're close because they think
it's gonna be like a dip and then come
back so you just have to prepare for the
dip wait it out and then it comes back
but you know so they have like a
approximate version but they don't have
this version of this is it
that's one issue the other issue is that
a lot of these preppers and um and
survivalists they're just thinking about
catastrophes like you know maybe there's
a flood and so i'm going to get ready go
to the mountains with my gun you know
that sort of thing
you know okay uh
fal says what do you think about
american elite building underground
bunkers will they have a chance
are they building bunkers well i mean we
don't know that they are but let's
assume that they are okay uh there's i
guess we wouldn't know that they are
yeah it should be a secret but uh
assuming they are uh the problem is not
building bunkers anyone can build a
bunker or whatever the issue is
uh can they survive even within the
bunker it's a self-sustaining bunker
yeah it's got to be a self-sustaining
bunker that's one issue the other one is
that you know who are they going to put
in there are they going to put
their bodyguards in there well the
bodyguards won't have to respect them
once they're down there the important
thing after the uh
the collapse is that you have people you
can trust that's more important than
saying i'm going to build a bunker
you can build a bunker but if you don't
have a doctor and you you have an
appendicitis you know need an appendices
what does it happen
uh you need uh
appendix operation you're dead
you know you have no one to
to cut you up you got people but
they're all dude all dude they all died
no no you can have a guy who isn't a
doctor do it
uh yeah i mean if you if you trust him
otherwise he's gonna use the knife for
something else so that he has more food
for himself right
okay and final issue
someone says i will tell you where the
sun is bill because i'm saying here in
frankfort we had no sun in the last
three months says four months of sun is
in sunny oslo oslo okay and here uh
all i can tell you is uh
what happened to me and that that you
know i put plants
in my garden i have a tiny garden
and uh here you'll see that uh the
circles
those are
peppers
and here you see cucumbers but they're
so small i had to i mean
yeah you need a telescope to see them i
didn't even think they were going to
grow and i just saw them by mistake a
couple days ago and they're growing fine
i guess they're going to grow
but uh because there's been no sun i
don't even think they're gonna make it
you know i i plant plants uh only to
uh learn about them okay
and um
you know not to feed myself
unfortunately
the spicy peppers the hot peppers oh
yeah we have those chicken yeah those we
do eat but other than that i don't have
a big garden
okay uh let's get on to the recap for
the month of august and let's do uh what
did you talk about in august okay we
talked about transparency
um opacity reflection refraction and the
faster than light travel of light
light travels faster tonight uh all
these have to do with the properties of
light as it meets objects specifically
objects people are concerned about like
you know
glass water air they say well you know
uh here we had um
light go through
this material and it's transparent and
then it for some reason it doesn't go
through the wall you know through your
cement wall
and you say why is this one opaque why
is that one transparent so we looked at
this
and
the first thing i want to mention is you
know one thing is for me to explain the
mechanism under the rope model of wha
of
how how transparency works how um
opacity works reflection and so on
that's one issue another issue is why
why is this material opaque why is that
material transparent
i haven't gotten to that uh because
right now i have problems getting people
to understand what i'm talking about and
i'm trying to compare especially quantum
mechanics mathematical physics in
general against the rope model and
people keep talking about going through
traveling through
you know they say well how does a robe
explain traveling through well that was
something that that you that you told me
you opened my eyes to the other day
where i you know
i always thought also like the light
just goes from my eye to the to the to
the light bulb but then you're like no
there's a big wall of air between you
people you believe so it's that air
relaying from air molecule to air
molecule the light to my eye and back
and i always thought of it in in terms
of like in space
it would go directly from the light to
my eye because there's nothing in
between but on earth it isn't the same
mechanism i guess you could say i mean
it is but there's more steps in between
yeah and it's more like uh like what do
you call it the newton's cradle or one
yeah it hits a whole bunch of balls and
then it hits the audio exactly
what we failed to to realize is that
what i have here in front of me
which i take into my it's not playing no
part it's a physical object
and the question then becomes does light
go through physical objects
through objects does it go through
objects and people say well it goes
through air well does it and so they use
this term go through travel through
and right now i have a big problem just
getting people to understand the theory
what i'm proposing so i'm just
explaining the mechanisms of reflect
refraction reflection before we even get
to a point before we can get the
question why you know
why is this one like that one is that
one like something else what have you
explained well uh so let's look at this
here we have uh quantum mechanics well
first of all here's uh here's all these
properties in one
uh
picture
uh you're we're gonna assume that's a
piece of glass somewhat transparent so
some of the light goes through you can
say right if we're gonna talk about
going through that's why i put a dotted
line there that's the way quantum sees
it so some of the light goes through
some of it refracts we don't know why
but it turns a corner right sharp corner
some of it reflects comes back and some
of it is absorbed and the whatever
is there is opaque and so these are the
possibilities okay and that's what i
guess that all happens simultaneously
well to some to some degree i think it
happens with all materials and i think
quantum will agree with a mathematician
they'll agree with that right
and but here's the quantum reasoning
okay this is if you can call it
reasoning
this is their line of reasoning okay and
what we have here is um
you know the the first argument is that
there are many atoms between you and
whatever you're staring at and that was
uh
what is it what uh how stuff works
officially says this
and you know they're pretty important i
mean they represent the establishment
and a they have people who are phds
working in there and that's what they're
saying many atoms what does that mean
well that means that if you put more air
atoms between you and the window uh you
won't see the window
and the answer is no
period you know
at night
i can't see the window but if i turn the
light on
you know flashlight on i can see the
window have i put or subtracted or put
more atoms in between my eyes and the
window obviously not something else is
going on so it's not a question of how
many atoms i'm going to put between well
no i i know that's the wrong uh caudary
experiment the right counter experiment
would be can you compress air
to the point where you can't see through
it anymore
well there's like a tunnel
and again that tunnel you compressed air
compressed air compressed there had so
many atoms in one place could you at
some point not see through it
well we don't know uh maybe maybe we
could do some experiment like that my
point here is that you know when i look
through three feet of or 10 feet of
water you know i can see my reflection
at the bottom of the pool and we did the
experiment
here with us where we put a mirror
in a trash can at the bottom of the pool
and we film the you know
you only have air there so you can see
yourself you say okay no problem there's
nothing there right
as if there is no air then we filled it
with water and we can see that the
lights continues to go through the water
all the way to the mirror comes back to
our eyes so light is going all the way i
mean if we're going to talk about going
through
light is going through the water and
coming back up
does the photon go through all those
atoms back and forth
and start hitting anything yeah without
hitting anything and when you have only
air it goes through all those atoms of
air and comes back when the light comes
from the sun
it goes through all i mean we have air
all around our planet a very thick layer
of air because that's why we can breathe
right and here we have the sun this
little photon it's got to make it
through all those gazillions of atoms
all the way to to your eyes i still
think they're the right the more atoms
that are between
the the more atoms that are there the
more opaque the leg gets i mean we know
this
because if you look off into the
distance
which is basically you're you're you're
you're getting the most air atoms
possible when you look off into the
distance to a mountain
it gets like blurry because there's so
much air between you and the mountain
is it or is it distance and dust and
other issues yeah but i'm just saying
like dust also counts like yeah i think
the more atoms you have
it does block light more but not to the
extent that you could probably block out
light like you'd have to have a lot of
because like even in under the rope
model
uh air molecules past like lose
uh some of the torque or the torsion the
energy whatever you want to call it
on in the relay
yeah yeah so if you have enough it would
lose all the the the frequency or it
would
[ __ ] the the frequency down less
okay but let's get to that point because
that's uh the other argument that these
people make
and that's this one says um
first of all an atom is mostly empty
space so if an atom is mostly empty
space according to uh you know the
official version right then all atoms
should be transparent all of them uh we
should
through cement walls
and so they say okay but
the way they explain why something is
opaque says electron absorbs a photon or
energy whatever you want to call it and
that's why it's opaque okay great what
is transparency well transparency
electron re-emits it absorbs and
re-emits
that's one argument they make the other
argument is the electron doesn't get
pushed to a different energy level okay
so we have these two arguments that if
it doesn't if the if the if the energy
of the photon
does not uh
affect the electron that's rolling
around then it goes through and it's
transparent otherwise it's absorbed by
the electron why does it affect it in
some cases
well
they say it is so but but there's a
worse problem with that and that's the
uh more fundamental problem which is the
photon is a point particle and the
electron is a point particle and you're
telling me that for all this all these
photons that come in and all the
electrons that are buzzing around in a
material air water whatever glass
you're saying that all these photons
that came through
uh they happen to hit
that electron and knock it knocked it
into a different energy level is that
what these people are saying
so uh yeah there's a lot of problems we
have the analogy for that it's it's like
a fly hitting and bumping into mosquito
in the sarah desert yeah
and so what are you doing here like it's
the only two in the
in the desert but they still want to
find each other
then we have reflection uh they say well
the energy bounces in other words the
photon bounces that's why you can see
yourself in the mirror the photon
bounces off the electron
or maybe it's against the proton they
never specify that you know what is it
bouncing against
you know but they just
assume that you understand that the
photon is hitting a brick wall and
coming back when it hits the mirror okay
that's why you see that i can see
because it's like a ball hitting the
wall yeah but when you get to the atomic
level now you're talking about yeah did
it hit an electron did it hit a proton
did it hit a molecule what did it hit
not only that why does the mirror
reflect bounce it back better exactly
than a wall yeah or where does it bounce
it in a given direction why why do you
see yourself straight in the mirror you
know when you stand straight in the
mirror you see yourself directly all
those photons are going back and
going forward and you know the molecule
that makes up the mirror is not a very
smooth molecule so if it hits an
electron goes that way and then it hits
a proton goes in a different direction
how many of them come directly at your
face and it turns out you look at
yourself in the mirror and it's a mirror
100 of them hit directly straight back
to you
okay refraction same thing what happens
there they never explain it they just
introduced snell's law talking about
angles okay
and they never said that's a description
mathematical description not an
explanation so you never learn what it
is diffraction they say photon can be at
two places at once great
yeah i mean who's going to believe it i
mean what kind of explanation is that
what do you have against the photon
being in two places at once uh it's not
two photons no no it does happen when
when i drink a lot of beer then i see
the photon out of two places at once but
that's an observer related
it falls apart and then at the end they
give you the the icing on the cake they
say we don't understand it and that's
philosophy anyways that's always the
punch line isn't it yeah so why didn't i
even come to you yeah where are the
actual scientists yeah they say study
math and you'll understand it okay yeah
so we never understand anything from
quantum mechanics okay
so that's why you know uh i have to
explain the mechanism first okay before
we go into why this is opaque why that
is transparent okay
and so here's one question you know
important question for the mechanics
here you have uh particles representing
the
light in other words the photons and
then you have the waves the famous
transverse wave and you have particles
that travel slower and particles that
travel faster you have the same thing
for the wave so the question is why
can't particles travel faster than light
why can't the uh wave travel faster than
light because then they'd bump into the
guy in the front right and uh yeah so
that's one of the questions that um you
you really want to ponder okay that's
another issue that i raised this month
okay getting back to this here we see
the following
uh we have
uh at least three proposals on the table
we have the particles we have the waves
transverse waves and now we have a new
one since
at least the beginning of the century
which is the rope we're saying it's a
torsion along a rope that interconnects
physically interconnects any two atoms
okay so we have three proposals on the
table okay
um what's the problem with the wave well
here's the wave what is it yeah well
well that's one issue but here's here's
the wave explanation they say the wave
goes through glass okay and that's why
they talk about traveling through okay
so they use that term goes through
travels through okay
in the case of uh the rope we're talking
about relaying okay there's nothing
traveling and so this is sometimes hard
to get to
people's brains because throwing a ball
is just easier well one is that the
other one is that everybody's been
drilled to exhaustion on traveling
through that that's the only terms that
they use and i'm saying that under the
rope model you have to think in
different terms altogether you have to
talk about relaying from atom to atom
there is nothing moving from left to
right the atoms are i mean for all we
know we could be moving the glass for
sure but if if everything in in the
universe stayed where it's at right now
we would still have the rope torquing
and the atoms pumping so you don't have
to have light moving from a to b what
you have is torsion okay and so we have
a different mechanism and until people
really get the their brains around that
it's a ball spinning a drill bit to spin
to pump a ball
basically yeah yeah and uh what you're
doing is relaying that signal to the
other atom the ball pumps yeah
spins that spin like torques the the
drill bit and the guy on the other end
gets the pump and he passes it on in
fact the torque goes both ways yeah
that's the other issue and that gives
you an idea of what reflection looks
like why reflection is straight ahead
rope is taught
and when you look at yourself in the
mirror every atom in your body every
single one of them is
mirrored to use that term
in the mirror okay it's straight ahead
back and forth along the same road now
it's easy to understand the mechanism
but when you say well hold it the little
particle hit the mirror and when did it
ricochet in uh you know to the right or
to the left that's the question you got
to ask yourself with particles waves
well you know the question with waves is
uh
we have no object called a wave okay
there's no object in physics called a
wave wave is a verb okay so you got
gotta identify the object that is waving
you know the flag waves but the wave
doesn't wave yeah what are the arrows
yeah and so the air is right there you
see vectors are uh
now represent quantities that have both
magnetic and direction so the arrows are
vectors what the mathematicians have
done
here is they
they put a mathematical concept and they
represent it with an arrow the arrow
stands for a vector what is a vector its
magnitude and direction and the worst
part is they have these vectors moving
very scary stuff moving three north yeah
you have
you have a number that has direction if
you can conceptualize that you got to
replace it with a indian arrow right so
you put an indian arrow you put a bunch
of these indian errors that represent
magnitude
and then you put them in motion
that's what's going on
the the dumbo part where dumbo gets
drunk and it's got all the
the pink elephants
they just starts hallucinating it's like
that like what are you moving what's
going on what is that
so so mathematics doesn't have a
physical interpretation so whenever you
see a wave ask what is it that you're
staring at what you're staring at as a
bunch of moving vectors what is a vector
with something already in motion it's a
number in motion
number that has direction
right and now they're going to move it
in a different direction you can't move
a number like you can't move the number
three well it's worse when you try to
move a movie yeah number three
we got motion
we got true understand no we're going to
go to the university and then then
you'll not understand like we do at
least okay and it doesn't stop there we
have the wave which is nonsense we have
the particles which are not particles
what you're talking about is a wave
equation you know
you're talking about a um when you when
you're talking about particle you're
talking about um a uh a wave function
whatever that means to you it's just a
number that they put out a location they
have all these locations moving so they
don't have a physical object ask any
quantum mechanics and and if you say
well do you really have a corpuscle
there and you'll find out what the
answer is the answer is no is it a ball
well that's a metaphor it's uh yeah they
don't have corpuscles representation the
number is the representation it's a meta
yeah and so it's it's all concepts
especially dynamic concepts which are
also moving and then planetary atom
nonsense you can't explain why the
electron doesn't fall to the center of
the nucleus or why it doesn't you know
drift away spontaneously i mean what
keeps the electron faithful to the atom
that's what you gotta explain and be if
you cannot explain that you cannot even
start your presentation electricity the
flow of
electron beads from atom to adam what is
uh compelling what's coming in contact
with each electron to move it
you know you gotta explain this you
gotta justify it they don't they just
say well the electricity is the movement
of electrons
okay what what compel the first electron
to move what came in contact with it and
what they're going to do is introduce a
concept force energy field
you know they can't tell you a physical
object hit that electron compelled it to
move to the
other
uh atom
and supposedly it either hit the other
uh electron and
kicked it to the next atom or that
electron for some reason already left
and left a hole and this guy occupies it
whatever leaving a hole means yeah yes
and so the question is
what triggered that first electron to
move
i mean what came into contact with the
electron the light switch
yeah yeah but see electricity is not
really a light
it's not a photoelectric effect where
you hit the electron with light okay
that's not what electricity is
electricity works a little differently
where you can you know battery works
chemically and the question is what
triggered that first electron to move
okay uh we have the beginning of motion
which not even god can explain okay
okay um
so uh what do we say well light does not
go through walls okay it doesn't go
through walls of bricks bowls of glass
walls of uh
uh air or water okay
what we have is atoms attached to atoms
and the uh the signal is relayed from
atom to atom are the break wall atoms is
greedy and they just don't relay it is
what it is they just absorb the whole
torque
don't pump at all right now all i want
to before i get into that because i
don't want to get into that issue right
now all i want to show is that first
quantum does not have an explanation for
travel through
because they have all these different
interpretations then they finally give
up and they we don't understand it is
philosophy anyway sometimes that's
that's it i'm not sure sometimes i
wonder how much further down the rope
hypothesis rabbit hole you would have
gone if you didn't waste so much time
with mainstream physics
well you got a chance someone once told
me first you got to destroy quantum
mechanics before you introduce your
theory so uh part of it is criticism and
part of it is uh you know proposing an
alternative so i have both but again so
first i want to show what's wrong with
quantity yeah but
but i just wonder how much that slowed
you down
like because there's a lot of rope
hypothesis mysteries that you can never
really get to because you're still you
spend a lot of your time still just
debunking what most people accept take
for granted take it for granted yeah
just well that's true i mean i could
look at different things that uh you
know different phenomena out there that
uh people have shown or seen in an
experiment or observation or whatever
and so they said well how do you explain
this how do you explain that and we
could go into all that but you know
right now there's this big battle
getting mathematical physics out of the
way a lot of it all nonsense i think
also it's it's more
as if the role hypothesis were at least
accepted to the extent that people would
run more experiments with it as a basis
then the experiments could have
different conclusions interpretation
interpretations obviously obviously
yeah
okay uh so
um
here we have uh the problem with speed
good old einstein is crying as you can
see
poor einstein why because einstein
proved mathematically and he's at least
credited with having proved
that photons travel at a constant speed
and you do not add the speed of the
train to the light that is coming out of
the flashlight that you have on the
train okay so he said photon travels at
the same speed no matter what
and it has a speed limit known as little
c photons travel 300 000 kilometers per
second but uh we could live with that
because you know otherwise we can't
travel to a to the nearest star even if
we traveled at the speed of light which
were a little distant from and so the
the issue is that they had to invent
this tachyon and they also invented warp
speed for hollywood so that you know the
uh
enterprise could travel to
klingon land you know at the speed of
thought you think and you're there okay
doesn't attacking come from the future
or something yeah yeah the marathon
backwards yeah but uh again they want to
cheat the point is they want to cheat on
the speed of light and why because
imagine if nasa told you look
it's confirmed
uh no one can travel faster than light i
thought that was confirmed yeah i know
it was but they had to work
and they had to do that because
otherwise you'd lose uh hope that we'll
never get out of this planet if you lose
you lose backing yeah
nasa would not have funding hurts the
wallet when there's depression yeah
because i mean why are we going to mars
assuming we ever get there but let's
assume that we send a few astronauts
there someday okay great does that mean
we're going to colonize mars yeah say
well yeah we will okay and the question
is what for so we have earth 2. yeah but
earth 2 is is a quarter of the size of
the earth
we got a little planet there
[Laughter]
one reason for sure to go to mars is is
kind of like like uh my brother goes to
iceland with his wife like to see the
sights
the nature of it when you on mars they
got i think mount olympian or mount
olympus or something yeah
yeah like just to see that you're like
that's a tall imagine standing at the
top of that or or b i think there's they
also have like a marianas trench kind of
thing that's even deeper than the
miriam's trench just looking down that
chasm would be cool
yeah but aside from that
it's just earth again
okay and yeah here you have a proof that
uh
light not always not only travels faster
than light
light travels
instantaneously it's known as
entanglement
you know they say one particle is
connected to
somehow
connected you know connected with uh
it's connected to yeah with
you got to take that as uh as a grain of
salt yeah it's connected to another
particle that's on the other side of the
universe when this particle goes
clockwise the other one goes
counterclockwise and if you turn this
one counterclockwise the other one
instantly
gazillions of miles away turns in the
opposite direction so uh they have all
these
explanations these physical
interpretations that involve not only
faster and light but instantaneous in
other words
you snap your finger you think you're
there you're already there
so
what have we learned about the physical
how mother nature runs her universe
that's the issue you won't get it from
mathematical physics or any so-called
scientist out there okay
what are the conclusions okay here we
have it uh light does not go through
that's the main point i want to make it
doesn't go through walls you atoms
through molecules through air or water
whatever it doesn't go through it goes
to
right it goes to and then it's relayed
okay so light is not made of particles
or waves light is uh an interconnecting
rope okay
and again it's relayed and the speed of
light is constant because of that why
because you exchange frequency for
wavelength okay and now with that we can
explain you know some some things for
example why
uh reflection is instantaneous
and straight ahead i mean every atom in
your body is reflected
not only instantly you could say right i
hate that word instantly because instant
involves time uh but it's straight ahead
first of all and then it's
it comes directly to you and the only
way you can really explain this is if
you have a rope there and turks in both
directions then it's easy to understand
this but if you say well hold it the
particle goes from my eye to the eye
in the
in the mirror and then comes back at the
speed of light is that what the particle
does and why does it bounce sideways
right or in a different direction the
ball it feels like it has a room for
error like it could miss yeah yeah well
can't miss yeah rope can't miss wherever
you go and here you you see it okay this
is the retro reflector stuff that the
mathematicians propose specifically
relativity
and uh what you have is the uh
laser being pointed at the retro
reflector on the moon and that's it like
that give yeah and we're not talking
about flat earthers here who don't
believe that you know that
we went to the moon or anything like
that but um we put a retro reflector on
the moon in fact there's five of them
three by the united states two by the
russians and what they do is they point
a laser at the
location more or less where the retro
reflector is and they get something back
and the question is how do you show this
with photons going one way first of all
right because yeah because
yeah because it moves right and so it's
it and it's going to warp space on top
of that and both the moon and the earth
move so how do you explain this you
can't explain it with it with particles
you can't explain it with waves explain
it right there perfectly we caught the
battles
we're playing ping-pong with ourselves
okay and uh so
and then the final one i want to show
here is uh
under the rope model
see how easy it is uh
if every atom on the earth is connected
to every atom on the moon it doesn't
matter if you put a retro reflector
there because every atom of the
retroreflector is connected before you
even start the experiment before you
turn the
laser on it's already connected to that
laser okay to whatever material makes up
the laser and so the moon can go
anywhere it wants in the universe and
light will find it because light travels
along the ropes that interconnect any
two
acts
the moon can go anywhere it will be
found
the moon owes the we will find you we
will find you oh you owe us money moon
okay so let's go with some of the
questions and comments that people made
okay one fellow says
says steam doesn't have shape oh what
wait there's a question yeah he he well
he questioned because i'm saying that
steam
doesn't have shape he says steam doesn't
have shape no steam moves around okay
steam is equal to boiling not to water
okay
shape is a static concept so boiling is
not so the problem is when people talk
about steam they think they're talking
about water now they're talking about
boiling they're referring to the verb
that's what the word steam
embodies does it yeah
well i'll get through that in a minute
i'll explain more detail but steam
doesn't have shape ion doesn't have
shape okay ion is a process ion means
you gotta remove or put an electron
remove
put verbs sorry
plasma doesn't have shape uh you um
have to remove and put in
or or put in an electron in order
something is plasmaing yeah it's like
saying solid yeah you have to ionize it
ion is already a verb i mean something
is happening okay
and uh so this fall continues and the
system was a state
that's even worse you worse that's uh
let me just quickly address that issue
uh to say that plasma is the fourth
state of matter as the people in the
electric universe gas plasma right they
they say that super super hot obviously
if if that's the definition of the word
plasma we're going to the definition
here okay we're saying if we're going to
define the word plasma as the fourth
state of matter
clearly there's no physical stand-alone
object called the fourth state of matter
what you're talking about is a
comparison against solid against liquid
it's gas solid isn't an object right and
so so people the people in the electric
universe have never understood that it
takes them 10 years to understand
something so simple if that's the
definition of the words plasma don't
ever use that definition again because
otherwise you're saying that plasma is a
constant unless they're talking about
blood plasma
okay but let's get to this issue here
the fella says
i'm so confused is gas an object or a
concept the fur is meaning me right that
i defer to the
wikipediandictionary.com for definitions
but then dismisses dictionaries and the
like as worthless
okay
steam is water as a gas aha is that what
it is
you define a gas as an object steam is a
sub type of gas therefore hence steam is
an object according to him okay or
he's trying to
saying that if he applies my reasoning
he ends up saying that steam is an
object i'm on his side okay good
will you
will you follow up by saying water is a
concept yeah will you follow the law by
saying water is a concept okay so let's
address this issue because he's not the
only fellow who has problems with this
okay
you need to see a psychologist
psychiatrist better yet okay
okay so let's go with the answers to
this okay and bear with me we're going
to go through several words
none of them are scientific in other
words we don't care about them in
science i'm just going to go
to whether these words represent objects
or concepts okay they don't make or
break anything in science in the sense
that
all theories of science fall apart
because of these definitions no i'm just
going to go
to uh whether these words represent
objects or concepts okay so let's keep
the context property pop quiz yeah okay
so here we have the word fog
we we typically don't think of fog as
something moving we it's like fog is
just that thing that blocks your your
windshield and does not allow you to see
i mean just technically
everything is moving everything in the
planet is moving i'm just saying the
word fog embodies no motion and you see
the word there suspended suspended is is
like a static verb you know we're not
talking about something moving we're
saying standing still in the air that's
what the word fog means so you're
talking about a tiny drop of water
that's standing still so fog in general
when we talk about the word fog in
ordinary speech we're not thinking of
something that's really moving that's
different than steam steam it says due
to boiling steam does not equal water
steam equals boiling when we think of
steam when we talk about steam in
ordinary speech again all these words
are from ordinary speech they have
nothing to do really in a scientific
sense but when we use the word steam
we're thinking about something that's
moving because we're talking about
boiling it anyone who thinks of steam is
thinking about boiling i think all of
these except fire and flame well that's
what i'm going through vapor talks about
temperature what is temperature a verb
okay in science in ordinary speech
temperatures are now in physics for
other purposes of physic temperature is
a verb so is the word condensed it's a
verb okay so vapor has something to do
with temperature and condensing
it's a it's a um
it's a verb
is it correct to substitute these words
for water no no but here assuming
someone wanted to use these in a
scientific uh but
again i'm getting i'm getting to that
because the issue here is context
context context is everything in science
if someone wanted to use the word yeah
as a noun it's gonna have to be related
to whether it's the context and let me
let me finish here and you'll see why
aerosols suspension a fine solid
particle fine but it's uh but usually
when we talk about aerosols we talk
about spraying you know where aerosol is
something that you spray in your in your
house usually that's the case and you
see there it says aerosol spray that
delivers et cetera et cetera okay so
usually aerosol is moved is used in a
dynamic concept in a dynamic context um
even though it's defined as suspension
of fine solid particles okay again the
word suspension meaning no motion it
implies the motion of the particles is
thrown out right and i'm talking about
how we usually use these words and what
the context is it depends on the context
that you're going to put them in mist
well missed you know it says phenomenon
phenomenon is already a verb okay caused
verb okay and you see this person
exhaled uh air cooling it's all has to
do with motion okay and that's the
notion we have a miss when someone talks
about mist usually think about something
spraying or something that's coming out
that's moving that's not the case
usually with fog or with a word like
cloud that you see there at the bottom
okay smoke smoke uh it again depends on
the context if you're talking about
smoke like you took a picture of smoke
well then you're talking about that gas
that
fog that's in front of you that cloud
that's in front of you if you're talking
about smoke like coming out of a fire
then you're talking about something
that's in motion and people in that
sense under that context will think of
smoke as something that is in motion
okay we have the word fire what is fire
well fires in oxidation it's a process
of combustion
and uh what is flame well flame is
usually refers to one of the components
of fire it's like if you you pulled a
piece of fire out and you took a picture
of it okay so flame even though flame we
know is moving right we all know this
right because it's
a combustion right but the word flame
usually refers to that piece that you
know like if i take a picture of fire
right
and i show it to a kid and uh that marla
i guess a 10 year old kid right he would
say that's fire and what's that picture
there well that's flame here let me
illustrate that for you so you know what
i'm talking about okay here's fire if i
can see it well get it at the bottom
here
give me a second
here's fire okay that's fire okay
and here's that's an image of fire yeah
and here's trigger
okay so what i'm saying if you take a
picture of fire you get flame now flame
is flame in motion yes it is okay if you
you want to take it to the extreme
you're gonna say yes the question is the
word flame represents to one of the
components of fire okay and so
in order to talk about fire uh in a
static sense or to point to whatever
that thing is
we call it flame and we say hey that
image there we'll call it flame
so you can say that flame is an object
under that context the context is very
important okay so again none of these
words
uh are scientific in the sense that make
or break some
important theory out there i'm just
trying to make sure that we understand
that
why
uh plasma is an object
a concept always a concept in the case
of plasma there there's there's no
ambiguity in the case of plasma but but
people say well you steam an object well
are you talking about the gas that you
took a photograph of steam of or are you
talking about this motion that's going
on that you're heating this pot uh you
know in your stove that's a different
context now you're talking about
something that's most in motion and
usually usually the word steam refers to
this vapor that's moving you know on top
of your pot that's what we call steam
now can you take a picture of steam yeah
but then what do you have we'll call it
gas how's that
okay because steam usually refers to
something in motion so context is
important
in the case of plasma there is no
ambiguity because the word plasma
embodies motion because
plasma means ionization and ionization
is already in motion you have to put or
subtract an electron that's what ion
means ion is not a thing iron is a
process
and uh because it's defined as a process
and that's what people have trouble uh
getting getting through those thick
skulls okay so someone uh also asks here
he says san says kangaroo is an object
uh meaning rational science right he's
saying that we're saying this okay san
says a kangaroo is an object until that
is moving gas is an object unless we
apply a electric charge
and you almost got it okay kangaroo and
gas are objects okay and that should not
be confused with what they do when you
say that a kangaroo jumps a jumping
kangaroo is not a physical object a
kangaroo is a physical object and and uh
same with plasma plasma here in fact i
have a picture of that
okay so that picture's worth a thousand
words
uh plasma jumping is a jumping kangaroo
i mean isn't it just again with all the
words that you just went through isn't
it easier to just talk about water
yeah and and that's the point you don't
talk about water you're melting water
yeah uh
that's what steam is a jumping water and
same with uh with this you can see
plasma has to be ionized the gas has to
be ionized because it's in the
definition of the word please understand
the the context that before one of us
dies okay
it's jumping gas yeah but they don't
understand they say well gas is also
moving yeah gas moves yeah
i mean depends on what you're the
content but gas i can take a picture of
gas i showed this the other day you take
a picture of gas uh blob a cloud a fog
that's there that's just sitting there
we call that gas we use the word gas to
refer to that image you can't do that
with plasma because plasma you take a
snapshot of plasma and you say is that
plasma well let's see has in the picture
in the static picture is the electron
being uh coming in is the electron going
out there's a ghost yeah i mean uh
people are totally thinking about it
they have mental problems if you don't
understand that plasma
you have to put or subtract an electron
that's part of the word plasma you
cannot extract that from the word plasma
and that's what you don't understand
you're getting angry at
uh dumb people mostly yeah yeah that's
their problem you shouldn't make it
yours but if you think about it it just
drives you nuts that people don't
understand
messages
if you think about it almost all
pictures have uh gas in the picture i
mean if we don't have oxygen the first
thing we have to understand is the
following the entire universe is moving
every bit of matter in the universe is
moving i'm moving with respect to
jupiter right now every single even if
you're not moving
i'm moving anyway whether i like it or
not so don't talk about that okay don't
don't use that as an argument the
question is the definition of the word
plasma already embodies
ionization ionization is motion you
cannot extract motion from the word
plasma and that destroys the entire
electric universe especially because the
word electricity is already something in
motion the word electricity embodies
motion so electricity is not an object
what does the idiot of uh the electric
universe say well bill why don't you put
your fingers in an outlet and find out
if it's an object that's not the way we
do it in science then science we have to
define this word
punch that's like saying punch is a noun
because it hurt
no [ __ ]
you now the issue here is the following
in science you have to define the word
object if it meets the definition it's
an object we don't put we don't run a
test to find out if if electricity is an
object but explain
i think they did they ran that
experiment many times
[Laughter]
in fact uh you know again if you use the
seed touch and experiment uh we cannot
see or touch the no but that's on the
other side of the universe according to
the to the electric universe
logic that they you just used punch
would be an object because it hurt but
that's not true it's the fist that the
yeah the fist is the object not not the
punches the verb
but explain that to these people
okay uh another grammar this is right
yeah it's just
they don't realize what they're saying
they just use these words without
analyzing them okay someone says light
is something in motion but you say light
is an object yeah we have to uh you the
word light is an informal word
we use the word light informally the
object
if you can't see through that you got a
problem okay the issue here is the
object is the rope the electromagnetic
rope that's the object now you can see
it's static there we can take a snapshot
of a rope and that's a rope okay
period we're done that's an object it's
got shape etc on the other hand light
informal word light is
rope which is moving in this case
torquing i guess light would be like
like plasma in that case yeah yeah
but sometimes we have some okay but
sometimes sometimes we replace the word
rope with the word light but hopefully
you understand that that's in the course
of of
uh yeah it's the shorthand
you can't say oh but you said light is
is a physical lab the rope is the
physical object okay i mean technically
you could give the whole presentation
without ever using the word light
yeah but i mean
you could talk about the electrical
magnetic rope twerking and you
technically but you get carried away in
the discussion you know how it is i mean
we i use a lot of ordinary speech as
well yellow card yellow card
you get a one instead of a 10.
okay another vowel says i thought the
polarizing effect is caused by the
molecules having the same orientation
which normally is only possible for a
solid he's talking about the fact that
we did this experiment with ants here in
fact that we turned light around
sideways and you know when we took the
water we did that oh yeah we we've moved
the water and i didn't bend light yeah
well no we've got water you know okay
and so uh it says
referring to this he says you know look
at our gas state the molecules are
continually rotating as well as moving
are they are they rotating do we know
this okay but this is what he was taught
and he just repeats it okay it might be
true it might be true but he just
repeats it takes it for a fact okay he
doesn't even challenge that he doesn't
even question it okay and this is this
is where we have a problem we'll see why
you would need a way to keep the
molecules polarized in the liquid
polarized uh how about gravity
so people are thinking of
electromagnetism how about gravity does
gravity pull on atoms
i mean we have the whole earth
covered with air right uh let's assume
let's simplify let's say all of air is
just two
uh oxygen
atoms and they form this air molecule o2
okay
are those
molecules oriented in any way with
respect to the center of the earth are
they standing
uh vertically you know one
oxygen on top of the other oxygen or are
they symmetrical with respect to the
edge of the earth i mean standing on the
center is also symmetrical yeah yeah it
is in a way but tell me which way is
that oxygen molecule
pointing or is it just curling around
i think it is twirling okay but this is
this is what we have to
this issue is not settled we need to
discuss it okay these people are just
memorizing college and they say oh this
is what i learned
something for granted no no we don't
take anything from brandon
somewhere
general relativity we don't take
anything from for granted oh you would
need a way to keep the molecules
polarized he says such as by generating
and what an electric field what is a
field what is an electric field we have
no idea there's no physical object
called an electric field okay field is a
concept means a bunch of numbers that's
all it means around a liquid whose
molecules are dipoles okay
okay so the question is do molecules in
a fluid
obey gravity
can gravity affect any molecule out
there like air or water
i mean there's a you're saying there's a
difference between
you want to make the distinction between
just being pulled by gravity and being
oriented by gravity or by
what is by gravity what these people are
referring to what they learned in
college by rote is that
electromagnetism
they're not even con considering gravity
at all
they never introduce gravity in the
context of a molecule yeah so they're
they're just talking about well you have
this electric field the magnetic field
you have the electromagnetic field
influence this uh molecule and here it
is in a solid here it is and a liquid
here years in a gas that's all they can
think of it never occurred to them that
maybe gravity does affect the molecule
okay and that's what we're getting into
here we're going to challenge this
fellow
okay and what he learned by wrote in
college okay so here it is uh here we
have um
let's go step by step okay here we have
my son and he's uh gonna turn that water
around
and the question is you know when you
turn a piece of cardboard around the
molecules you'll rotate together with
your hand
the question is if that happened also
with the water in there okay and let's
look at a
similar
related scenario here we have the same
picture okay but we're gonna leave water
just standing still for three four days
okay on the table for example right here
i just kind of illustrate it here
does water move
do all these molecules i mean is there
turbulence inside that water
if i leave a a can of water or a bottle
of water or a cup of water on the table
for 10 days no one moves anything in
anywhere near by it
do those water molecules are they in the
turbulence or do we have waves in there
are the
atoms or the molecules moving around are
they drifting are they it depends on
where now we have to be specific because
they are moving but you're talking about
waves that's a big distinction they're
not making waves clearly but they are
vibrating because all yeah but i mean
all all atoms vibrate okay but let's so
what motion are we talking about okay
now we're going to look at the motion
that we're talking about okay so
you got the question hopefully you
understand the question the question is
whether there is turbulence in the water
that i left for 10 days just sitting
there we have calm water we have no
waves no anything that we can see at
least the you know
here's a better way of asking that
question uh the water molecule on all
the way to the right is almost touching
my palm there in the picture yeah does
that one ever does that one yeah let's
say touching the glass this almost near
my palm does that one ever migrate to
the left side yeah i mean uh does that
is is that water moving is it do we have
a river there is there even if it's yeah
is there a river is there a motion there
at all or are all those
emotions i don't like saying motion
because there is motion but we're
talking about specifically it's a grand
motion especially how are the water
molecules oriented
yeah okay what is the tilt of the water
molecule that's what i'm getting at okay
tilt okay
that's the level that we're talking
about here okay let's look at an example
here here's the water molecule okay
let's go slowly one step at a time
here's a water molecule we have two
hydrogens and one oxygen okay
let's assume and again under the rope
model for those of you who are
interested oxygen is comprised of eight
hydrogen atoms that's how the sun or the
star or whatever squashed
or had to squash four hydrogen eight
atoms uh eight i'm sorry eight hydrogen
atoms to make that oxygen
uh atom okay that element okay so we
have two hydrogens one oxygen since it's
got more ropes
i'm going to position it arbitrarily not
that i know but i'm just going to
position it arbitrarily with respect to
the center of the earth
in that direction okay you're saying the
center of the earth is down here yeah in
other words under this uh scenario not
that i know i'm just gonna do it
arbitrarily okay just hopefully nobody
shoots that in my face okay i'm gonna
say that the molecule is oriented like
mickey mouse's head okay we have uh his
chin at the bottom
the ears at the top okay we got that so
far okay let's move slowly now i'm going
to turn what did you do you turned the
glass around right now
rotated it 90 degrees right okay now
here's the million dollar question is
that what happened to the water molecule
did you turn the water molecule to 90
degrees
or did you leave it in the direction
that you see on the left did it stay in
that position or did it move around
okay let's look at several uh water
molecules so that we know what we're
talking about once again here it is okay
this is one scenario and this is a
second scenario which one is it
and if you look carefully the red ones
are the uh oxygen okay and in the case
of the one on the right it's always
pointing towards the center of the earth
because of gravity not because of
electromagnetism but because of gravity
what is gravity under the rope model is
eight uh
ropes uh being tugged or uh being
connected to the center of the earth
okay
so which one of those is happening when
you
turn the
water the water flask or whatever uh 90
degrees well we did this yeah experiment
so we should know right oh we do know
how experiments were we we proved one of
these
i just don't know which one it is okay
so so those are the two scenarios and
the question is it's got nothing to do
with electromagnetism at least as far as
i'm concerned i mean i could but i'm
going to leave that part out i'm just
saying let's look at gravity only
gravity does gravity affect the molecule
does gravity maintain the low the tilt
of the molecules
okay that's the question before you okay
and so um
you know that's one thing you gotta
ponder
uh let's move on and look at now
oxygen we're looking at air now here's
the air molecule okay two oxygen atoms
okay we got that very easy
it's a dumbbell yeah question is uh does
it do this does it stand on its head
okay let's remove this
does it do that when you turn
the balloon around the balloon is full
of air you turn it around does the air
do that inside does the
oxygen molecule
you know stand on its head
that's the question before you and the
issue here is does gravity affect that
molecule okay
and so here we have a bunch of molecules
of air which of these is the case
does it
go from horizontal to vertical or does
it always stay horizontal that's the
question for you and the issue is
gravity okay let's forgive momentarity
at least with electromagnetism okay so
those are the questions before you and
the issue is that nobody has ever asked
these questions in the history of
uh so-called physics okay no one has
asked these questions
and so now we're asking the question
that's why we don't take for granted
what uh
what they teach in college i mean it's
not even that no again like you said no
need to ask the question so there's no
answer for it even even in mainstream
they couldn't
they were never high enough to ask that
question yeah and uh why do we ask the
question we asked the question because
we're saying that every atom is
connected with ropes
electromagnetic ropes very thin very
uh
tiny ropes that are connected from atom
to atom and now you're you're saying
okay if you have this water molecule for
example water molecule okay and the
oxygen is tied by eight ropes to
whatever atoms are in the center of the
earth to each one of those atoms like
eight robes to each one of those right
when you turn that
floating um
molecule around remember there are other
molecules sitting on or hitting itself
but we discussed that the other day
hitting its elbow against other
molecules
does it maintain or do they all maintain
the same location with respect to the
center of the earth or do they tilt 90
degrees am i just i made the distinction
between water and air in this case
because
with
water it has the mickey mouse ears so it
has more i thought of it more like a
buoyancy issue it's more of a density
issue where the oxygen sorry the
hydrogen ones
can't go past the oxygen one so it can't
really
push past the the the
the neighboring oxygen uh molecule atoms
but with
oxygen like just air if it's just two
o's there's no buoyancy issues they're
both the same weight the density doesn't
play a part so it's just turbulent it
doesn't matter if you turn the balloon
it does turn but like water i think the
buoyancy keeps the hydrogens on top
the only issue i've got there is that
they're both pulled by eight ropes if
you pull one down and does that one beat
the other one it's like
violating galileo galileo says all
objects fall at the same
rate to the center of the earth now we
know why they're all tucked by ropes or
they're all connected by ropes and so
the question is can you have one
molecule one atom of the molle of the
air molecule
pull more than the other one i think it
does because again it already fell as
much as it could it's it's suspended
it's held in place by the other oxygens
and just turned my my answer to you is
food for thought that's something you
got to ponder
we definitely hadn't thought about it we
discussed it quite a while but we i
don't think we're reaching that
agreement
or agreement not what i want well but
you're wrong
[Laughter]
okay another issue
uh oh okay i just wanted to show that
you know you have air first water and
then air around the planet okay i showed
this the other day
and the question is do they maintain
that position all around the earth okay
and i'm saying that they do or i'm
saying that's my okay but i'm suggesting
that they do because they're all
connected by ropes okay i'm suggesting
the hydrogens or ones are correct with
the oxygen
oh that's what i'm saying you have
something against oxygen that's your
problem yeah yeah
okay anyways those are things to ponder
okay especially for flat earthers who
don't understand why water curves around
the earth well there you see why it
curves they're all all the water
molecules are connected by ropes to the
center of the earth yeah so that's the
issue okay another issue moving on here
quantity
someone says
oh i don't know why it always goes that
okay uh is a quantity not then equality
magnitude of a physical object an
adjective describing the object okay uh
the three apples the three-ness the
magnitude of three uh-huh would be
an adjective the quality of the apples
themselves in in ordinary speech
uh
there it is quantity is a noun okay but
even there and he's saying well we're
using it as an adjective because we're
qualifying objects not object but
objects because when you talk about
quantity you're talking about objects
plural right
and the issue is uh quantity is an
adverb it's not it's not a noun for
physics not ordinary speech not
mathematics we're talking about physics
physics quantity is an adverb why
because it has to do with the word
number what is number it's the verb to
count and here we've illustrated it so
you know what the verb to count is there
it is
it's um when you move your finger many
times you give it a name if you move it
once you call it a one remember
and that's what the what the
number is
you're being patronizing
that's one way to describe it yeah okay
so number is how many times you move
your hand yeah you get a name you give
each direction of your finger
a name
i guess called three that guy's going
for right that's what a number is okay
number is a verb and so number is a verb
and quantity qualifies some object then
we're saying is quantity is an adverb
that's why it's an adverb okay the
qualify quantity does not qualify one
object in fact it's uh it just it has to
do with counting okay accounting is a
verb okay
so all these things uh we have to look
at the context again you have to learn
the language of physics and that's
different than the language of
mathematics versus the nonsense that
everyone from newton to
stephen gawking you know created all
that nonsense that wording is no use
of no use in physics okay in physics we
use a different language because we're
going to give a physical interpretation
that's what science is about science is
not math science is not making
predictions science is not using words
like field and
force and mass and energy those are not
scientific words science we deal with in
physics right we deal with objects you
can't do physics without an object so
you need to define the word object and
all the words that are important within
that
within the foundations of physics okay
somehow follow says here says uh we
can't define black therefore black is an
object because i'm saying that if you
can define it it's a concept
in science or in physics we point to
objects okay and so i'm saying well yeah
we can define the word black and you
look up the word black it says a color
that lacks hue and brightness and
absorbs light without reflecting any of
the rays composing it um
light
black means no frequency okay it's the
absence of light
it's you can say the color of space
because space
uh no no no
no no it's not not an adverb it's it's
not not in the case of black but but
that black is an exception let me show
you why let me show you yeah it's an
exception yeah let me show you why it's
the only color that's an exception by
definition why because the word black
refers to space it's the absence of
light
that means we're it's the absence of
anything what we're talking about is
space so black is a color of nothing
okay it is black yeah black is black is
the color of nothing now let's get to
let's get to another color that the
swallow raised it says yellow okay now
we're getting to colors to real colors
right
okay so he says people doing the st the
stream told me yellow was a concept but
couldn't define it
i said yellow was an object and pointed
to it like so he said because you can
point to it right that's what he's
saying a couple guys answered him says
colors are processes much like a tornado
or plasma yeah
they are nothing more than the flow of
what link lengths of the rope at
particular frequencies okay listen to
what the guy said he's got it right
there okay another guy pointed out he
says object that which has shape nothing
to do with pointing okay so let's
clarify this let's make sure we
understand what the issue is here okay
let's first address this pointing issue
okay pointing is an observer related
phenomena
okay
but in mathematical physics an observer
is a witness that what they want to do
is introduce testimony in the religion
of math okay in physics we don't do that
we don't accept witnesses okay no
observers allowed the theorist points in
that sense he's an observer you can say
but not to present his testimony he's
presenting an object and that should not
be confused with giving testimony
witnessing
the theorist names an object so the
crowd can follow the presentation okay
and then we have the word object is that
which i shape as this fellow said there
concept the word that invokes
or embodies two objects you need a
relation between two objects and that's
what we call a concept you must define
the the word object before you define
the word concept because you need two
objects to define the word concept
and you must define distance location
before you define motion or exist
because they depend on those two words i
think a big problem with a lot of what
you talk about is yeah
you're talking about the rules
the foundations
but but the rules of giving a
presentation is is the bottom line
exactly we're talking about it that's
what physics is but we we're trying to
understand that yeah yeah but explain it
and understand but there's not a lot of
people giving presentations
it's like the presentations they give
are nonsense because they're trying to
give up
what what do people at quora you know
where people ask questions what do they
ask what what does the common man out
there on the street want to ask if you
say look uh here we have two men here we
have two magnets right
and uh and they pull each each
one pulls the other one and so the
common man out there he doesn't want to
know math he doesn't want an equation
he says how does it do it how does
mother nature do this magic trick or you
have a simpler one you know you let go
of the pen or a pencil and it falls to
the floor
why does it always fall to the floor not
to the ceiling that's what he wants to
know he wants to know straight stuff and
for them for for the common man that's
physics he wants to know the the process
the mechanism
and these guys come out and say well you
got to take a course in math to
understand this oh math why math well
you see because you have the force and
the magnum the mass and the energy and
what is
identify the physical object that came
in contact with the skin of the pen
that's how simple it is that's what
people the common man wants to know and
that's what he understands by physics
and what the mathematicians have done is
that well we don't understand any of
that because we
uh can't see the invisible things so we
don't think there are any invisible
things there because we can't see or
touch them so all they do is mass
math okay all they do is mathematics and
they equated science so-called physics
right with mathematics and they say
physic the language of physics is math
that's what they say and this is the
problem because no the language of
physics is illustration you need to have
you need to illustrate the mechanism
otherwise you're not doing physic you're
doing math and that's what we have today
just a bunch of math and irrational
explanation funny enough there was a
celebrity i can't remember who it was
they asked i think neil degrasse tyson
if math had anything to do with science
and everyone laughed at her
i just thought it was like it's taken so
for granted that it's like ugh this poor
dumbass doesn't even know what she's
asking okay let me let me explain uh uh
the last part of y'all really need to
know math to know why the fan went to
the ground
okay here we have yellow is yellow an
object well uh the guy kind of was
playing devil's advert but there's
nothing wrong with that that's okay i
have no problem with people playing
doubles advocate okay so if that was his
intention that's that's just fine no
problem
staring at a wall not at yellow that's
what you're staring at okay you're not
staring at yellow okay you're staring at
an object that is yellow what is yellow
yellow is a comparison again what is it
you would have okay let me say earlier
about black is is aren't colors adverbs
because it's it qualifies the all of the
speed at which the rope is
yeah but all of them except black
because black is the absence of rope
black is
space nothing that's black but that's
not exactly true because you have a
black cardboard no that's not pure black
it's like they think they took uh black
hairs of black men in africa and they
took uh black hairs of men in japan and
they say the true black
or the black is black is the guy in
japan not the guy in uh unbelievable i i
thought it would be the other way around
no you're saying space is blacker than a
japanese guy's hair you got it because
it has no color so black is a special
color if we're going to go very
quality color yeah if you can call it a
color okay but staring at the wall uh
not at yellow okay that's the first one
the wall is the object yellow is the
adjective okay in this case it's an
adverb okay because we use it to qualify
the wall but at the same time yellow is
what a frequency so we're talking about
motion here okay and there you have it
adjective is a qualifier of a noun okay
and uh
there's no standalone object called
yellow okay obviously
in quantum mechanics yellow is a
frequency okay in fact uh it is so also
for
the uh rope model and
yellow is uh 580 nanometers that's the
wavelength or the link length in the
case of the rope model that's a static
concept but uh when you talk about
frequency
yeah
yeah in other words uh nothing is moving
when you say this is the link of a rope
you need to take a picture of it yeah i
can take a picture of a link in other
words that's all we're talking about how
long it is okay in that sense um but uh
then it says uh
in the case of quantum it talks about
5.16
10 to the 14th hertz okay that's that's
the frequency supposedly you know little
beads moving through the detector and
that's the frequency of yellow so yellow
is something in motion that's my point
okay yellow is a comparison because you
wouldn't have
yellow unless you had blue and red and
other colors
if if everything in the universe were
yellow we wouldn't have the word yellow
we wouldn't even have the word color
okay so that that's something else you
got to think about okay that's not the
case with objects okay
unless there's a single object in the
universe then you would need the word
object okay and we say yellow is not
independent
meaning that
in in the case of yellow it requires
other colors otherwise we wouldn't have
a need for the word yellow in the same
way you know a halo requires an angel
because without the angel all you have
is a ring or a plate and magnetic field
requires a magnet because otherwise you
don't have a magnetic field in that
sense these are all dependent objects
therefore they're not objects because
they are dependent
an object is it independent you know a
circle is an object yeah i know that
hurts people
but circle is an object because i don't
need another object in the field of view
i can put a circle all alone and i don't
need to have any other objects and i
call that specific pattern you know i
call it a circle i don't need to have an
a square
i need a square to compare the word
circle against the word square but uh
but i can point to a circle without need
for triangles or squares okay
in that sense it's an independent object
i mean can you point it yellow without
the color red next to it
yeah but if yellow is the only uh color
in the universe then uh you know then i
would need i would not need the word
yellow okay or whereas
yellow whereas with circle if you had
two circles now
you you have two yellows they're both
yellow but with two circles it's circle
a and circle b i guess no no the the
question the issue i'm trying to uh
address here is that
i can have a circle
that's all that god made in the universe
he made a circle
and he made it two-dimensional
and it's got no
he didn't put it against paper he didn't
put it against anything he just made a
circle in the middle of space that's how
powerful god is okay now he made a
circle there do i need a square do i
need a triangle no he calls that a
circle he could have called it x
i see an object there it stands alone we
refer to that object that specific
object that circle we could call it x we
could call it y it doesn't matter he
called it circle fine so we call it
circle we're getting really abstract
yeah but the point is i don't need the
word square i don't need the word
triangle that's not the case with the
word halo of an angel i do need the
angel because otherwise all i have is a
ring
not a halo or a plate
do i get through
going back to black i still don't like
calling space black
is it is it more accurate to call to say
it doesn't have color
than saying that it's black
because black is what you said it's a
it's a low frequency it's it's it's a
japanese guy's hair a black
japanese but then if you're gonna go
with that argument then you got the
issue is tell me what the frequency of
black is okay
what is it you're saying that here you
have a rope i mean you have white light
what is light a white light well it's a
mixture of many lights some different
colors
it's a low frequency
is that well yeah okay you could do that
okay i guess it has zero frequency that
means it's not a rope but that's that's
that's that's space okay but then it's
like you know you got 620 nanometers
that's red right and if you got 625 well
you don't have red anymore now you have
orange
okay but now is black black black is
black i don't know it's black black
there's different shades of black
there's different frequencies and so the
question is what is the exact frequency
of black space no
that's incorrect space has no color oh
correct and no color is black no
that's not true
air isn't black
uh area is not what
okay last issue before we opened the
floor in other words it's going to take
all day here
experiment is very much
part of science default says uh it is
the largest part of the scientific
method there is no wave theory or
particle theory there is a wave particle
theory there is no wave theory you know
particle theory but there's a wave
particle theory okay uh which has
experiments that back it up that is what
makes it a theory uh no a theory is an
explanation not not the evidence that
you present uh to
convince people okay so science is not
about persuading and convincing which is
what you're talking about they're
backing it up backing it up as evidence
means you're going to present evidence
to the jury to persuade them to believe
in your theory
belief in a theory is not explaining a
theory so that you understand it so
one is objective the other one is
subjective and the subjective one
belongs to
religion now we're going questions i
didn't see that many but okay
go up there let me go scroll through the
comments here
okay what do we have
hello hello cheers
uh
survival of the random is that better
than survival of the fittest
no i'm saying we shouldn't qualify
we should not qualify um
things in success and survival of the
fittest okay i don't think we need those
in science okay
people can have their opinions but the
issue is
those words only interfere in in science
has anyone came come up with the
definition of yellow after that a lot of
people in the chat wrote the nanometer
yeah i mean uh yellow is is just a
frequency okay just the synthesizing
right uh making it short
yellow is is a frequency yellow is a
comparison you need other colors
otherwise we wouldn't have the word
yellow at all
and a yellow obviously is a qualifier of
the wall the wall is the physical object
yellow is what it is it's like saying
the wall is big
well the wall is big is big a physical
object or are we comparing big against
little you know that sort of thing so
yellow is
obviously a relation it's not a
standalone physical object is reality an
object
uh no reality is uh an object that has
location reality is a synonym of exist
and exists is defined as an object that
has location now you talk about reality
like my reality you're talking about
yeah it depends on which ordinary you're
talking you're talking about the
ordinary speech version we don't use
that word in science there is no such
thing as reality in science
no it's not this thing is reality no not
in science it's science
care about reality
means that your state of mind what is
your reality or that sort of that's
that's where you know that's ordinary
speech uh in science in physics we
physics is the science of reality in
other words it is
we don't care about reality in physics
but it's the it's the science of
existence meaning we have to define the
word exist which is a
synonym of the word real not reality but
real what are we talking about we're
saying that we have to define this term
i guess exist means an object that has
location i guess with reality they mean
all that is in existence yeah but i mean
that would be a
for the universe if anything except that
uh what we talk about all that exists we
call it matter yeah that's that's that's
the word yeah
you can say that reality is bad or
universal but see the word reality has a
different connotation yeah so it's more
subjective like my reality
if i take shrooms i have a very
different reality and we're talking
about your feelings yeah not really
what's wrong well yeah reality is also
mixed up with consciousness yeah yeah so
we forget about the word reality
completely
you could use it but it's just
counterproductive i don't use the word
conscience i don't use the word reality
those are follow four letter words
just get me through i'm looking for
question marks
[Laughter]
is your idea that molecules and fluids
do not rotate jiggle etc like billiard
balls bouncing around classical study of
gases teaches
well molecules do as you said here my
good old son he said they vibrate okay
remember um
the atom
is pumping okay it's uh doing its
quantum jump
and it's uh torquing the ropes it's
being also influenced from outside what
we call electromagnetic influence right
uh we have other atoms influencing it
either through light or through touch
okay through the rope there's a lot of
motion going yeah there's a lot of
motions going on so
the molecules any molecule even the ones
that are in steel you know stainless
steel they vibrate okay so there is
motion always okay
what i'm talking about is here you have
a loose molecule such as air or water
okay more or less it's it's not tied to
a crystal lattice that's what i'm saying
so now this molecule not only vibrates
and jiggles and does all its quantum
jump and all this kind of stuff but now
the question is that molecule is tied to
the center of the earth here on earth at
least right it's tied to the center of
the earth does that molecule when you
turn it around one one that belongs to a
fluid
or to a gas right when you turn it
around
does it stand at 90 degrees to where it
was before
or does it maintain its
tilt its orientation with respect to the
center of the earth that's the question
okay that we have to answer
okay i hope i guess you didn't really
answer any questions you asked you asked
you're the one asking questions
i'm the one
here
i'm answering with a question because
that's what we need to figure out does
that molecule rotate or not if it's a
fluid or you know
gas or water or whatever
i'm not sure i understand it but i'm
just going to read it
rationality forbids creationism plus
destructionism i guess the atom can't
come in
from nothing yeah
and nothing can become an atom
in a in a universe with only two
tangible parentheses cubes set to
collide would they halt or bounce
i think they would just stick together
wouldn't they if cubes
well uh that's a strange situation
because
what we're talking about is
a very hypothetical situation right
where you say look you have two cubes
what set them in motion first of all
okay that's the first thing we have to
try to figure out okay and you're seeing
they're coming towards each other and
the question is are we talking about
these cues made of a single piece each
or are they made of parts because
they're made of parts we can't talk
about the cubes we have to talk about
the parts that make the cube and why
they're coming together and if they're
made of atoms for example are they
connected by ropes so there's a lot of
questions there i think there's a
follow-up question here okay but let's
assume for a second we have two cubes
okay they're made of a single piece
they're connected by a single rope okay
that's i have to make some assumptions
here on your question and so the
question is first of all why would they
come together
why would they rotate
okay so so you gotta explain rotate the
origin of motion well not i mean rotate
in that case in respect to what
right because
max principle says that everything is
interconnected so when you twirl around
you're pulling against all the stars
okay with the rope model we can
understand that uh with quantum and
relativity no way you can figure that
out because you need to put concepts in
there you can't figure it out the
physical mechanism but then the question
is if you have two cubes tied by a
single robe and they're both made of a
single piece do they rotate do they come
together what set them in motion
and then even if they come together and
they hit what they're under the rope
model they're eating into the rope
okay and so the question is are these
cubes elastic or inelastic and so you
got a lot of questions here it's a not a
simple question to ask because we need
to know all the little details of your
presentation of your the intangible rope
has a little bit of friction this halts
motion to a degree doesn't it
the intangible rope has a little bit of
friction this halts motion to a degree
doesn't it well um
that's a very important issue what we're
saying is the remember the atom eats
into the rope because the rope makes up
the atom well it goes into it and spits
it out yeah the question is how much
friction
does it or or or does it
swallow the slack and spit it out the
back end when an atom moves through the
rope okay so
is there friction i don't know if we can
talk about friction when we're doing
that okay because the atom is sliding
through the rope and the rope is going
through the atom going to the next atom
now here's a follow-up to that yeah
shouldn't process these like magnetism
and the row crossing over itself in
general cause the universe to one day
grind to a halt
but i think we answered that with the
fact that the motion always goes
somewhere
it's it's like it's it's the metaphor we
came up with with the with the ball of
water in
space a moving ball of water in space
has nowhere to pass that motion onto so
it's not rubbing against the fabric of
space or anything there's no it's not
there's no loss of energy energy doesn't
go anywhere
it's i guess it's the same thing with
creationism and destructionism there's
no loss of energy it's always just going
somewhere else and anyways uh
beginning uh
matter beginning motion is out of the
question and in the same way ending
uh motion and an ending matter so that
matter turns into space that's out of
the question
so there's no creationism in the sense
of
something appearing from nothing and
there's no destruction in the sense of
disintegration where matter turns into
space
i think that the question is also
answered by the fact that if we assume
the that the universe as in the matter
in the universe is eternal and and is in
motion then it has always been motion
always will be in motion correct that
also that's where i learned it that's it
i cannot imagine the beginning of motion
the end of motion cannot be imagined the
beginning of matter in the end of matter
but if you can imagine it uh please
explain the process uh hi bill can you
make a thesaurus for your foundation of
physics the old one is hard to find and
has several broken links love the show
huh
uh make a decision
i do have uh foundations of physics uh
there's not that many words all we need
is a 10 15 words
that you need as foundations for physics
so so it's not like you have a thesaurus
it's like uh
a little glossary that's all it is and
essentially i i pointed out some of
these words you can find them in my
website also uh you
stupidrelativist.com it's uh
look under what is it um i think it's
glossary
at the bottom of the page you'll find a
link there for glossary it gives you a
whole bunch of words and no there's uh
there's a better one there in there i
put the foundations of physics you got
to look at foundations of physics
includes the important words that form
the foundations so we don't need a
thesaurus it's just a glossary of maybe
10 to 15 words
i can't remember how many of them
question for bill how did you get from
light being a rope to those ropes
connecting all objects in the universe
and how did you get
from that to them being gravitation
well let's go with the first question
the first question is you know when you
follow the robe and ends in an atom when
you follow that atom it ends in a rope
and so on down the line and you have to
say at some point you got to say well
where does it end i mean is it like the
mathematicians like to use that word
infinite
and the answer is no and i'm saying if
it's not infinite it's a circle which is
one of the
uh
issues that mathematicians bring up and
yeah if you have a circle what you're
talking about is a thread which looks
more or less like this you know like a
rubber band it's a
closed-loop circle okay that's uh how i
ended up with
the i started with a rope i ended up
with a thread and what was the second
part of that question
uh and how did you get
from that to them being gravitation well
if if
you know what's interesting i discovered
gravity first i discovered that in
november 97
and uh
i said look uh and i did it with lines i
did not know anything about the rope at
the time so i did it with lines i said
well you know when an object approaches
another one you can imagine all these
lines you know the two objects are far
apart and you have lines connecting
every one of their atoms and then if you
put them closer together you know they
open up and so i figured out gravity was
simply a question acceleration of
gravity
uh just how close and how far an object
is from another then a few months later
in january of 98 uh i came up with a
rope model
not the rope model but
i i was getting
close to it and until february i really
came up with the idea of one day i came
up and said oh uh we have this rope i
was looking at
waves and i essentially you replace the
wave with a rope and that's when i
finally made the connection i said oh
hold it uh if every atom isn't connected
to all the other atoms and here i had
the idea of uh
gravity that all atoms were
interconnected by these lines i'm just
going to replace the lines with the
ropes and that's how the theory came
together the grand unified theory came
together
under what authority
do you announce yourself as a scientist
in this irrational non-science nonsense
well i got a phd degree from um uh
harvard university oh [ __ ] really yeah
phd stands for phony degree
i thought i thought it was a pretty huge
dig and everybody who's got a phd knows
it stands for phony degree because
obviously they cannot explain a single
phenomena out there okay so no we don't
use authority in science they can do
math good though
we don't care about
degrees okay and science in science we
do not start by saying oh i'm a phd i
have a master's degree and you should
start all your shows from now on with
that
no the way we do it in science we say
you know it's like i always give the
example you have here the the world
champ box the world boxing champ the
heavyweight boxing champ of the world he
walks down the street
and he finds this guy out there and they
start arguing
and so
[Music]
they say okay let's fight let's resolve
this like men
and the champ says
do you have a degree in boxing
and the other guy said well we'll find
out
when one man remains standing and it
turns out this guy is
and it turns out the little guy this
unknown garbage the crap out of the
champ of the world so um you know forget
about authority it's uh you gotta listen
to what people say what uh what they
what the arguments are what they can
explain and right now we have no
explanation whatsoever from people who
have big degrees from the biggest
universities on the planet so so much
for phd's and uh
and degrees and
big universities ivy league colleges
harvard cambridge oxford bill they
cannot explain anything that question
about the water molecule rotating when
it is standing still on earth's surface
can easily be answered if the earth
doesn't rotate can it not
we
we had oh we had a big talk with this
gentleman here you know um about uh the
influence of other molecules funny how
quiet i am on this show
i don't shut up we came up with a
different scenario similar to yours but
this was the scenario we came up with we
said what if god right here is all
powerful god and he made a single
molecule okay he put it water molecule
forget about the earth because we're
polluted by all this air that's around
us no no he puts it on the moon where
there's hardly any gravity and there's
no air no nothing okay or
you have a little bit on there yeah
we're gonna assume there's nothing there
and he puts a molecule there molecule of
water or molecule of air okay
and the issue is that we came up with is
that there's no other influence other
than gravity right and so the question
is
does it depend on how positioned
how god positioned the molecule to begin
with i mean if he positions it standing
upright or or sideways is that how it's
going to stay with respect to the moon
and keep in mind galileo's uh
test that you know
he said the way he explained it he says
you got two rocks tied by a stone
okay
no tied by a rope okay whatever uh and
and so you drop them and one stone will
not go faster than the other stone and
so now you have this molecule that you
created on the moon they're tied by a
rope right uh it could be water it could
be uh
o2 okay and the question is is it the
way god put them originally
or
will they realign itself with respect to
the moon based on how many ropes are
connecting each one of the atoms that
comprise the molecule
and so we had all these discussion a
very detailed discussion in my mind i
was thinking if you put the the water
molecule the mickey mouse ears and he
put it like perfectly
like vertical like
where the the height the
hydrogen
atoms are are perpendicular then it
wouldn't fall over but if god put it
tilted then it would that would tilt
over and fall as if you had a basketball
with two tennis balls and you just put
it there it would fall to one side but
let me tell you what the issue was the
issue was you know again here's the
pressure here's the test if you put some
water in in a tub whatever and you leave
it sitting there for 10 days whatever
until it's completely still
okay
do the water molecules listen to the
question do the water molecules point
all
in the same direction towards the center
of the earth
have they all
jiggled aligned themselves in such a way
that they finally stabilized so that for
example the oxygens are all pointing
towards the center of the earth that's
the question and we and what uh anz was
saying was saying well it depends on the
molecules that are next to the ones that
are they're elbowing against and you
cannot create a scenario where you have
you know like in space
yeah you have no no container okay so
now we have all these water molecules
you take an astronaut he takes a balloon
full of water he pops the balloon i have
this blob okay it's just floating in air
but we're assuming he's in the middle
between two galaxies
no matter no nothing there okay
do those water molecules align in a
certain way or not are they tilted again
are they all tilted in the same
direction or are they just twirling
around in any old way
and now we step one go one step further
those molecules approach another galaxy
now we have gravity
will they all align
themselves and what you have to keep in
mind there is
if they align themselves that means what
part is moving faster than another and
that's forbidden by mr galileo
so keep all these issues in mind we
discussed this in great detail but so
far
we're still debating the jury's out
dirty's still out okay two cubes each of
a single piece they are tangible and the
only things that exist no rope
they were always moving they were always
moving
now they are about to collide do they
stop stick to each other or do they
bounce
i don't know
without the rope now we have a different
scenario well uh you're saying thank you
there's no reason there's no reason
they're already moving i mean i think
they would bounce because there's no
reason they will stick to each other
without the rope well the the question
here is uh are they elastic or inelastic
that's the inelastic was yeah yeah but i
mean okay that's what we're comparing
we're comparing whether they're gonna
stick together okay meaning inelastic
and whether they bounce meaning they're
elastic okay
and the question is what material
they're made of you're saying they're
made of a single piece well
the question again is
is that material elastic or inelastic
and that's a question of a definition
in other words
you do the test okay and then after the
test is finished you say oh they bounced
we're going to call that elastic oh they
stuck together we'll call it inelastic
so it works the other way around the
test
the the you're trying to define the word
elastic and you're trying to find the
word inelastic and you define it based
on the results of your experiment it
doesn't work the other way around saying
let me predict
okay we can't predict
okay not not in the scenario that you're
putting up
that you're presenting what you're
saying is the opposite you're saying
you're trying to define the word elastic
you're trying to define the word
inelastic with your so-called experiment
does a spring
compression slash tension
violate rationality when it begins to
move quote-unquote out of nowhere when
let go
not like the fingers squeezing
stretching it pushed it into motion with
it when they go you just kind of let go
and it moves on its own
well it's got a
you've got it under tension you know you
you're compressing against its nature
it's nature's to be you know
uncoiled and you try to coil it like a
slinky or you're pressing it and it's
gonna tend to push out
i mean i don't know what the issue is
here the string this the spring the
spring pulls pushes on itself what's
that about balance forces equals no
motion well for that you got to go at
the molecular level
forget about talking about forces and
all this mathematical nonsense you got
to look at the molecular level what's
happening to the molecules that make up
the spring
that's what you got to look at you know
i mean are we talking about a fluid are
we talking about a solid that's what you
got to look at you got to look at the
crystal structure to answer that
question okay so
you know this is the issue if the bowl
of water is sitting on a table for a day
i feel like those those like rabbis that
play chess
and ask those really deep questions if
the bowl of water is sitting on a table
for a day yeah
then your model then by your model they
would have to do a full 360 turn thereby
agitating the water so by your own
theory the earth is stationary you agree
i don't know where you got all that
i mean uh don't put words in my mouth
the molecules wouldn't i think as he's
saying the earth is turning so it's
turning the molecule with it
well the question is the question is
again uh we have several motions we have
a good point that i never considered if
the earth turns yeah right like that
turning what spinning and moving around
but but let's just keep the spinning for
that if you spin the earth does the
molecule spin with it
or does it
again
we have several issue here
if you take a piece of cardboard or
something that's solid the earth turns
the cardboard moves okay no problem
there now we have a fluid like a river
or you have air around the earth the
question is do those molecules also
rotate because of the motion of the
earth that's a good question and and the
issue is first before we can answer that
question is we have to answer if if the
molecule maintains its location its
position its tilt its orientation with
respect to the center of the earth at
all times
let alone
twirl sideways does it maintain always
the
like in the case of water does it oxygen
always point towards the center of the
earth
all else being equal in other words that
you're not going to touch anything
you're going to let that molecule just
sit there and again the question is all
this air that's
enveloping the earth
that's out there that's just floating
around with the earth around the sun and
rotating with it
are those molecules forget about the
motion where they're twirling we're
talking about are they even pointed
towards the center of the earth it's in
a given direction are they tilted
sideways or what before you do anything
else that's the first question you got
to answer okay and so unless we answer
that question the the higher level
questions are whether it's road trip
they're not higher level than just other
questions yeah but i mean you need this
is a precondition immediately it is you
need you need to turn in the others
because if if if it does move if it's
standing on its head then you have a
different scenario for the other one
right right absolutely in your model
light is traveling through the water it
hits a molecule and is then transmitted
through the other side
what is preventing it from being
re-transmitted in any which direction
ah but uh that's a question i still
won't won't don't want to answer because
what he's asking or essentially is why
is something opaque and why is something
transparent
right now we have problems with people
thinking that light goes through
atoms okay and so that's the first
question we gotta resolve i haven't
addressed yet the whys why one object is
opaque why another one is are those
september questions uh probably so
okay okay so i'm not going to get into
that yet you have to prepare the the no
that's not a one-liner
first of all
it's a little more involved but the
issue is right now i'm having problem
with people understanding the going
through issue they keep saying well what
how does light go through and why don't
you know and so
we got a problem with it going through
because the person who proposes going
through first is
require
is proposing one-way mechanisms okay one
may one-way objects uh such as particles
or waves and we've ruled out particles
we ruled out waves so what do you have
in in exchange first you gotta explain
that you gotta you gotta defend your
your you're going through uh theory okay
that's that's what you got to do and
until you can do that you've got no case
we've got to destroy quantum mechanics
first probably most important questions
if homosexuals
are attracted to men
why do they speak with a lisp
[Laughter]
good question
uh
that's it i think
okay any questions that aren't asked
okay yeah just keep up for next week
okay then we'll see you on sunday i will
start the new month with that we'll see
you then bye bye bye guys have a good
one